we had to have an interpretation as to
who won last week because whoever wins
takes the lead and hosts the joint
collaboration
chris got week one i got week two
coming out of week three because chris
you were ahead of me against the spread
by two games
no straight up by two games i was ahead
of you against the spread by one game
the interpretation was made
that it means more to to get it right
straight up so as long as that's the
consistent role that's applied
all year long i have no problem yeah
we're both doing well that's all that
matters that's that's the
thing that's pretty good i'd like to be
doing i'd like to be doing better
straight up but i'm happy against the
spread and i'm very happy best bet
seven one and one which just raises the
pressure to keep it up all right it does
we're gonna keep it up with the
week four most important match-ups draft
is there a trivia question or not
i see that i ask you a trivia question
but i don't see one so let's get to it
okay let's not dwell on the fact that
somebody didn't do their work
chris you take the first pick well i
think that um the one that jumps out to
me right away
is the chief's wide receivers versus the
patriots secondary
i mean that's where i look at it i
really do i think that's going to be a
huge matchup i mean we know this is the
best secondary in football
it's the best passing attack in football
i don't care what the numbers are i'm
taking kansas city if you ask me to take
a passing attack in football
because of 15 and the weapons around
them i don't care what about anything
else so i'm taking them
and you know with the patriots having
issues
you know with their front seven i just
not a great pass rushing front seven
i'm not so sure they're gonna be a great
run stopping team
you know they're gonna have to put
pressure on this secondary in this
football game if they want to come away
and win it
uh and because of that i just think you
know gilmore's match-ups against tyreek
kill and what they do there
is going to be one of the big components
of the football game
and there are different iterations under
that umbrella of the chiefs patriots
game i had down
mahomes versus belichick because i think
that's what it boils down to
that's the chess match because mahomes
is the guy who's going to do things on
the fly
belichick is the guy that's going to try
to stop him with that
configuration of the defensive players
but there's all sorts of different ways
so i'm going to stay away from that game
you're right because spags mcdaniels is
another one i wrote down you know that's
an interesting one they got history
and they're both thinkers outside the
box thinkers will do different stuff
that they've never done to each other
before that'll be a cool
you're right there's a lot of matchups
in that game we could have gone to
there's no doubt
all right i'm gonna go to a matchup that
i ha you know it dawned on me last night
what we do this is the one segment of
the show that we try to do some
preparation for
i looked at all the games and i started
thinking where are the intriguing
matchups and then it dawned on me that
nick foles super bowl winning
quarterback with the philadelphia eagles
back as a starter taking on the cults
head coach
frank reich offensive coordinator of
those philadelphia eagles if there's
anybody out there
that knows how to keep nick falls from
being the best that nick foles can be or
just
just intriguing yeah what will the colts
do
how much can reich help the defense to
to keep nick foles from from beating the
cults and it's it's a great reunion
you know we're just a week short of a
super bowl 52 reunion between nick foles
and tom brady how about a super bowl 52
reunion between frank reich and nick
foles on sunday so i think that's going
to be a great matchup
to the extent that those memories from
2017 in the playoff run
infiltrate this game and the way that
nick foles may or may not perform
when it's time for him to go out and
cement his his uh
stranglehold on the bear's starting job
yeah no i i hear you i i had something
so
i had frank wright vs chuck pagano
written down just because chuck pagano
was the ex-colts head coach right
defensive coordinator of the bears now
but i i hear that all the way i mean
that's that's an interesting one
it really is foals isn't a big spot here
to
like you said grab the opportunity to be
the starter forever there
and frank wright i just can't speak
enough about him
you know for a guy who nobody really
wanted to hire as a head coach like i'm
i'm blown away by frank reich's offense
i think he's got one of the best
offenses in football
there's always people open there's
always creative schemes every week
different formations different ways of
doing things so
that would be a cool thing to watch in
that football game like i said earlier
this show one of the under the radar
great
great games of the weekend you know been
a little
uh infected here or if affected
literally in this game that i'm gonna
talk about but
i can't wait to see derek henry versus
that steelers front seven
are you kidding me i mean that big
sucker and like you've always said
jim brown type presence just boom boom
boom i don't care who you are
well the steelers are like that too they
don't give a damn who you are either and
the steelers defense for my money is the
best defense in football
the front seven is scary good i mean
they are unbelievable
so i am interested to see how that
shakes out because it's a battle of
wills we know tennessee wants to run
that ball
and pittsburgh is a type of front seven
that's going to take great pride in not
letting that happen
yeah you know and again that's another
one where you could go different things
coming out of that game i was going to
go mike vrable versus mike tomlin
because you got the two coaches
under different circumstances how do you
get your guys ready for this delayed
game
rainbow raibl was a steelers draft pick
too you know we think of him as a
patriot
he started his career as a member of the
steelers 1997 third round pick so
there's a little extra there
as well i'm sure anytime he plays the
steelers all right i
am going to go with hmm
how about this fits magic or if it's
tragic
versus the tragic seattle seahawks
defense
we saw ryan fitzpatrick play extremely
well last thursday night
we know there's a shelf life on ryan
fitzpatrick playing extremely well
and when we least expect it you know
don't tell me about shamrocks and sit
please chris don't talk about shamrocks
and where they may be
but at the same time they're lined
throughout the inside of his body
the seahawks thank you for that gesture
the seahawks defense is not good
so maybe we're gonna have a shootout in
south florida between russell wilson and
ryan fitzpatrick as long as he can
continue to be ryan fitzmagic and the
chances of that happening
are enhanced against that defense i
don't think it's crazy either
i think that could be one of those games
that's a little closer than people are
thinking it might be because of what
you're saying
you know the seahawks are going to give
you opportunities to make throws down
the field
and fitzpatrick we know he's he's going
to do it i mean he'll he'll do it
sometimes when there's a you know seven
guys there so
he's certainly going to like that aspect
of it and and the dolphins with flores
and what he can do and he's got some
pretty good corners even though he's got
no byron uh
byron jones uh xavier howard's still
really good too he
i would think he could match up with dk
metcalf and that that would be a good
interesting matchup within the match
up there um i don't know where to go
here i got a
two more written down that interests me
but i think the one that i would like to
talk about
i i really look at i'm gonna go to the
ravens washington football team game i'm
i'm very fascinated by that matchup
and okay let's say let's say ravenzo
line versus washington d-line
that's where i want to go because i
think that's going to be a huge part of
this football game if they their d-line
can slow down that run game and kind of
push around baltimore like kansas city
did last week
whoa we're gonna be back into like okay
pressure on lamar can he make the throws
and do those things
i just think that's a match-up that's
really going to dictate whether the
ravens are in a close football game
or in like a blowout game against
washington and yet again that's another
game i was going to take but i was going
to go the ravens versus themselves for
the reasons we discussed earlier in the
show will they be able to recover from
what happened to them against the chiefs
and take care of business against the
team that they should beat all right i
am going to go and this is one that is
influenced by
knowing you and talking to you and
working with you i'm going to go
derek carr versus josh allen because my
guess is
josh allen is becoming one of those guys
that your guy john gruden
is very excited about and loves what he
can do and
loves how he plays the game and derek
carr's probably been hearing it
all week long and and not that john
gruden's going to get a shot at josh
allen ever
but i i just this is probably one of
those where derek carr wants to show
that he can match up
to a guy who's becoming the the not the
flavor of the month the flavor of the
year for the nfl yeah right yeah yeah
and he better be careful though
because i don't know if the bills will
give you a ton of opportunities so don't
try to just match josh allen just to
match josh allen
just play the game the right way win the
game and nobody even cares
you know that it'll get swept under the
rug
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports